i'm not super optimistic about this gun
safety bill there were like five minutes
during which it sort of seemed like hey
democrats propose something that
republicans are at least saying they can
they are willing to consider
but the problems are number one if you
look at what republicans said mitch
mcconnell's statement has so many ifs
it's hard to even understand it he's
saying we are sort of like conditionally
interested in the framework and looking
at whether the framework translates to a
bill that resembles the framework
it's like okay so they're probably not
going to support it but maybe even more
importantly the bill is so weak and i'll
accept any progress i really will but
this bill does nothing about limiting
access to high-capacity magazines it
does nothing on gun insurance it does
nothing on assault weapons it's touching
barely the edges now we'll take it if
it's all we can get but it's one of
these situations where it sets up
republicans if the bill passes to say
look you passed the bill and we didn't
reduce gun violence right because the
bill is crap